vous m'entendez mais des tests n'en fait
pas trop
vous êtes ces énormes que vous soyez
tous les deux manu allen ça fait un
petit à petit comme un duo ouais il ya
même ni quotidien pour le second tour
allez l'homme crola
salut les gars il est bel homme à toute
heure du jour et de la nuit colas deux
heures entre la veille
c'est beau
mais qu'est ce qui t'a l'est surpris
nico
roadie
fois c'est pour dire même fiche ouais il
a le même physique que moi c'est beau
ouais et franchement il te manquer 10 cm
et toujours emi c'est ce que m'a dit ma
femme aussi
juncker on a droit on a le droit salut
tout le monde dans le tchat on est
désolé pour le petit délai on est là
avec manuel and nico jus est ce que
quelqu'un peut me dire où on en est
cette draft parce que moi je peux pas
regarder en même temps l'âge et trop de
trucs à faire
il faudrait biais du second tour sont
sortis déjà ok et alors ça dit quoi donc
c'est andrew neymar dans 31 indiana
hockey et c'est khaled du stone en 32
orlando d'accord alors qu'est ce que
vous en pensez ce que déjà vous pouvez
me dire qu'ils rendent le dernier
julien dis moi qui est andrew née marthe
s'il-te-plaît
nord canadien de 38 ans m 94
grosse
expérience internationale il a connu
deux
équipant réussi
je confonds tout le temps de faire taper
sur les doigts florinda florida florida
florida de course olympique au hockey et
gonzaga depuis deux ans
bon voilà
c'est un peu tout faire on attaque
bon voire d' équipe walfoot
c'est peut-être un petit peu spécial
ça va il ya un petit peu court au niveau
physique et pas trop s est pas un
athlète
vraiment la tête d'un peu courant
diminue de l'envergure on parle pour
aller rapidement
manu pas des choses à ajouter toi tu les
aimes bien ça n'était chouchou
j'aimais bien c'est puisse l'aimer bien
tu as changé chez chargé je me batte en
d1 à ce qu'ils
progressent et finalement il n'a pas
fortement de prouver aussi il reste
quinze jours super fort à la page super
forte dans l'organisation mais
la taxe foncière qu'ils sachent ou
moyennement bien après j'aime bien le
j'aime bien le fit à indiana je trouve
que ça peut ça peut le faire on dit à
mon troisième meneur ça peut être
intéressant
après
c'est
un joueur avec ma maman tient la très
bonne remarque de falcon qui dit
apparemment il est des gros résultat au
combat n'est ce pas tellement les les
résultats alan sait plus ce qu'il a il a
dominé dans le match où il a joué en
fait
l'escrimé geda vraiment vraiment dominé
l'a montré sa capacité à gérer les
attaques gérer une attaque ce qui pourra
faire en sorte ide en tant que meneur
backup 6 à ceux ci c'est physiquement il
meurt pas trop de tirs est quand même
assez important
falloir qu'ils tirent mieux
il va falloir qu'ils tirent mieux et
alors - la question que je me pose c'est
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent indiana drafté
ce gala en 31
tu t'es pas fait la réflexion quand même
moi je l'aurai alors tu es là c'est
clair mais
souvent lent rennes joue des équipes
tentent des meneurs backup la plupart du
temps ça marche pas parce que les
meneurs backups et ça marche pas un des
meneurs labellisés bac es pire ils sont
pas assez bons c'est donc
je sais pas j'ai passé avec j'aurais
plutôt de rareté un ailier ou les choses
comme ça hydra venant de rooney mara
devant john hardy quand même ouais ouais
ouais c'est vrai le ventre militants de
leurs militants
laïcs est parti en 30 à denver métier
watson
ça ressemble bien à denver de faire ça
si
[Musique]
j'allais dire un truc
j'allais dire ça ressemble un peu à ce
qu'ils ont fait l'an dernier en gros ils
prennent du du jeu qui va pouvoir jouer
tout de suite apporté on va dire à
l'entraînement et dans les rotations
quoi
j'adore les drafté des joueurs qui
apporte à l'entraînement ça me faisait
mais après j'ai du mal à dire autre
chose ce vendredi j'aime beaucoup mais
mais c'est vrai que le l'aube side ne
paraît pas folle
après je reviens sur le premier tour tu
m'as demandé la surprise challen du
renne
non mais alors dit charlotte bon on en
parlera on vous demandera dans le chat
quand est ce que ça me dit ça vous va si
on fait un débrief samedi pas moi je
voulais faire un débrief juste pour
taper sur les hornets ont fait n'importe
quoi détroit qui fait ivy et john quand
même ouais voilà bah oui mais en fait
pour qu'il y ait des équipes qui
réussissent bien faut qu'il y en ait
d'autres notamment les deux mais quelle
heure je sais pas à 21h samedi après tu
voulais peut-être sorti risuqe samedi
soir peut-être qu'on peut faire ça en
début de soirée je sais pas
du stade entre aussi en trente deux
hollandais
qui allaient vieux stanway c'est ce que
j'ai mis bien bien rattrapé j'étais en
train de me perdre dans l'animation je
pensais que pierre allait revenir qu'est
ce qu'il fout parce que moi je n'étais
pas dans le mode animateurs ce soir je
faisais des blagues sur le côté quoi
caleb houston 32 orlando shooter grand
il a glissé dans la draft est en hausse
continue du port devrait sortir il faut
une sortie
à oui il l'est pas il est pas oui c'est
vrai je vais le sortir manu pourquoi
pourquoi il a glissé
et qui allaient plus
bas au vu de sa saison tout simplement
on fait on attendait un un joueur
beaucoup plus fort que ça beaucoup plus
impliqué que ça après les tombes et plus
ou moins dans un petit bourg be à
michigan où ça a été il n'était pas dans
son rôle du touya jamais trop accroché
au concis au jeu de jason ward et
finalement il a pas eu trop de réussite
au tir ce qui est sa force première
normalement
mais c'est vraiment ça qu'il a fait
noter son camp il était en excuses et
ouais saison c'est son kata et
et on pensait qu'il avait qui pourra
revenir finalement n'ont donc crise
comment tu penses sa venue oui marie
cocoloko aux raptors le jockey de là il
ya du live manuel sa de phrases courtes
merde
je réponds aux questions de l'animateur
du poids seront de l'animateur du
passeur de plats merci manu de répondre
au casting parce que nico
diawling aiment pas ils ont drafté que
du front de quoi là là c'est bien d'y
aller nous williamson d'or quand même en
bref c'est jay leno williams et john
soutènement ouais mais ils vont garder
pour eux
comment je sais pas s'ils vont garder
tout le monde quand même enfin boris
calame ouais mais henri iii faire ce pot
aux roses maintenant je pense qu'ils
vont garder bah ousmane oui mais déjà
l'aisne tu vois bon
bah ouais je pense aussi il va peut-être
jouer dès l'année prochaine et ousmane
plutôt l'année d'après quoi
ju tu m'entends ou pas soit en traîneau
est ce que tu peux tu peux twitté le
live ou pas ce que là je peux pas faire
mille choses en même temps
[Musique]
williams ekoloko avant que la vague et
et
ben ouais bah ouais alors que notre
petite oreille elle nous avait dit qu'il
avait quand même une petite promesse en
début de second kamagaté qu'on a encore
des
[Musique]
acquis le pic en 35
allées les quinze ans un choix tient
certes
ils ont acheté 35 ans là ils ont acheté
le pic 35 d'orlando
oui
ok de la barge croit
au rebond et l'alaric un bon moment et
puis on a cinq qui viennent m bape et
qui là bas il a tout arrangé
[Musique]
bien sûr fort
alors ce serait énorme
pour s'écrire jilin williams alan oui
c'est bien c'est mon gain switcher bah
oui me gêne un bien meilleur américain
meilleurs joueurs pour prendre les
passages en force de tout le
potentiel de passes potentiel de tir
j'aime bien franchement c'est un vrai
bon piquant des jeux 3e tour un
1,45 charge par match provoqué insignia
beaucoup
c'est super intéressant c'est un peu le
souci du sonneur l'an dernier contre
courte alors ils sont pas tous provoqué
pas assez de passage en force non
secteur intérieur post 3 4 5 quoi as tu
l'aimés match est à tchita jerry
williams je vais récupérer jérémy
robinson earl qui va revenir sa blessure
ah oui j ai pas mal de champs et de
matériel c'est intéressant radio avec
chez avec guide et moi j'ai pas atteint
je pense qu'ils vont perdre des matches
mais ça c'est pas grave moi j'aime
américaine pas des matchs intéressants
en grève
je vous laisse sur jérémy lyn williams
les gars soyez fort débit n'est ce pas
pour nous parler j'espère que guy santos
va être drafté j'ai fait inscrire cordes
j'espère que tu es à derniers amicaux
tous les je voulais que je lis ton
rapport sur le dos santos c'est ça oui
guillarmé guillarmé dos santos carballo
ça dans le ballon j'adore je comptais
rester jusqu'à kamagaté mais je me dis
que là il me reste que deux heures
sommeil c'est peut-être bien qu'il y ait
entente embrasse nico doit efforts top
basique on a le pic des lakers tu le
vends live ou pas vas-y vas-y devanlay
max christie
le fils de doug
michigan
message c'est un peu le même poste
donc ils ont ils ont lâché le de
l'argent à une imprimante de téléphones
portables pour pour lui
il est chez claude choix
c'est une bonne question ok bon avant de
dire des bêtises vous laisse
pierre ouais ça va tu peux reprendre le
lead y est ce parce que moi je n'ai pas
la télé donc je peux pas faire les choix
en direct et où tu vois ce que je veux
dire ah mais moi non plus je n'ai plus
du tout est ok mais je te laisse saint
blaise à la vie de rires ouais ouais
donc on en avait plus de 35 c ça avec ma
fille christie absolument note christie
donc le fouteur de michigan state
par contre j'ai pas en 32 ya eu juste y
aller les russes tant qu'elle est plus
temps en 33 j'ai pas eu six ans qu
locaux qu'aux locaux donc ça sert aux
raptors oui
en 34 on a john williams
oui
et 5 max christie ici et donc la
prochaine équipe à choisir en de cloques
sont les blenders normalement si le
ciapol trade
oui les blenders
donc matt christie qui va en parler je
sais que le gala effet un tweet sur lui
je crois de mémoire
et même une vidéo avec nicolas lang qui
a exactement le c-max soleil exactement
donc nicolas lang pour ceux qui sont
dans le chat et qui connaissent pas
c'est peut-être le meilleur shooteur
français actuellement pour faire simple
lors du tir en plus est un bon choix
celui qui
dit qu'il faut foot est comme si on
était dans une caisse voilà un troyen
non moi on oui en fait c'était le pic
était à portland de base normand
normalement ça détroit
à oui tu as raison ça a changé dans le
trade exact exact exact alors là le
détroit ils vont drafté déjà dès mardi
et vont faire des grands phoques à tout
le monde
ercis s'ils font des données revit après
avoir fait du renne et ivy
ça ça peut vite changer l'image de la
franchise pourquoi
j'ai pas dit ce qu'on apporte déjà de
crissier aux lakers est ce que c'est un
rôle qui était nécessaire
a ajouté hu est
presque il est vrai jamais
l'année dernière ils prennent reeves qui
est vachement plus
ready
soit sur routes planes ça que les bots
you lie ce système n'est pas joué
[Musique]
donc là on y sera le pic des trois
appareils je ne vois pas je sais quoi si
les gars vous avez arrière pour voir
martel to man live non c'est les risques
ah oui toi tu étais sur bin et c'est
fini c'est ça mon fils oui c'est ça
non les
les deux pipo et mario là vous avez des
six sur quoi je peux dire
c'est pas sur les spins
magnifique bague bizarre ils sont ordina
avec son ordinateur ok ok non mais sinon
bah on suit
gauche non mais il le site de la nba tu
peux pas prendre ouvrir le site de la
nba sel ça l'est mais pas en direct
je regarde alors c'est vrai vous avez
raison dans le chat
pour qu'ils y analyse c'est pas fou
le jedi vit d'ailleurs lalanne et manu
en ont parlé en plateau chez la force
tim wallace et après kemba il va se
faire couper je te rassure mon petit
zouker
ans déjà c'est déjà fait je crois
presque
mais sur le discorde ya un lien ils nous
disent pierre qui est cgg dayez padawan
un fidèle de nos de nos lives qui nous
disent ah
voilà donc max christie
moi je les moins vu jouer que vous ici
c'est qui il fait quoi ils mesurent
combien
j'étais petit muret ses richesses dans
la grosse équipe à trois ans c'était un
vrai spécialiste du tir sur le poste 2
ou autres crus à michigan state un peu
compliqué au début comme tous les
fraîchement une soupe miso mais fur et à
mesure de l'année il a montré je pense
qu'il ya la plus belle mécanique de tir
du tas la cuvée quasiment mais c'est un
pur pur shooteur
le choix de détroit
vas-y annonce
annoncé leurs hôtes il a way
gabriele sine die ils vont peut-être je
sais pas s'ils vont le faire venir tout
de suite qu'ils vont stoch
donc tu parlais de la plus belle
gestuelle nico il disait que c'était lui
ouais ouais je serai tête de plus belle
gestuelle qui ceux qui suivent
gabriel est proche il a donc un athlète
qui shoote mettais trop léger pour pour
faire une baseline de son profil
nefic les kings ce point hold up font un
titre aig le cross est un mal gré au
dallas qui prend déjà donné a remis
ou quennec parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas jo dan hardy et un
illettré de leur pic à dallas qui monte
c'est contre 202 second et qui vont de
dallas va prendre j'ai de nardi
et ben c'est moi j'aime bien donc ils
ont pris quoi
dallas ouais bah ils ont pris personne
très détendu pour christiane route mais
ça là ils ont donné des yaourts et du
miel aux kings en échange de jets de
nardi
dans dans le scénario idéal
schénardi c'est un genre
le créateur secondaire à côté de luca
qui fait reza un petit cap quoi c'est le
voilà c'est leur petit doigt nous est en
création secondaire s'est laissée dans
trois dans deux enfants qu'ils soient le
meilleur que spencer 10 me dit quoi en
fait non seulement
séparent compliqué dès fois parce que
dinwiddie est un immense joueur de
basketball mais
c'est dur je les ai écoutés au take
you et carris nevers mais
voilà franchement dallas tu tentes qui
s'étend à peine deux secondes tadu caté
talent prague de luca pendant dix ans
encore va pas avoir beaucoup de choix de
draft temps des coups comme ça
mais kim ce parc comprend pas
exempt derrière nous qu'on croit les
disques avec une oreille que le temps
plein aux
as et le seul argument on essaie un peu
de nuance et avec manuel tout à l'heure
j'ai essayé de forcer la main à lui pour
qu'il soit gentil avec eux
[Musique]
ouais
mais je pense que je pense que je pense
que keegan murray
avec un bon créateur comme
sabonis est une menace qui met de la
pression sur le sarkome fox
je pense qu'il va être efficace en fait
j'aurais pu faire de 18,8 je pense
parce que il ya quelque chose tout le
monde le caricature comme
bon un gars qui faisaient du pick n pop
et et qui pouvaient driver parce que les
gars monté sur son tiers qui a demeuré
sait
combien un 1,3 point par possession sur
les post up c'est n'existe pas
incroyable talent mais il a pris des
couleurs corps de stade avancé
c'est la plus grosse progression aussi
un point d'une année
ses
soieries et en fait il se bat je vous
conseille si vous lisez l'anglais leu
leu leu passes tu à lui à l'anoci le
portique de pizzi web
c'est un scoreur d'opportunité
extraordinaire
en fait il va aller il va pas poster
quand le gars est plus costaud que lui
c'est juste qui sent le bon match up et
après il a les appuis là la force pour
eelv a dominé au rebond offensif
en fait il fait tout le temps la bonne
action en fonction de qui a en face de
lui la différence c'est que les gars les
gars en fins les gars en face de lui
vont changer c'est tout finalement les
gars du top 5 que tu drafts et pour qui
sait pas besoin de s'adapter ouais bof
oui bah après si tu aimes pas et vit que
tu dis que ça arrive au tard il reste
plus personne
avec cette chanson je suis temp à chaque
fois l'ennemi
tu peux te tiens tu vois pour info j'ai
récupéré un live de effectivement sûr
sur youtube ou que là on en est à john
hardy qui pensent partir à sacramento
équipe i pleuve ou pas du coup
c'est un mélange de soulagement et il a
les boules à l'étranger abbring était
d'écouter aussi de partir en
3d une tête incroyable basse et surtout
qui voit en 1 et 2 0 a finalement
c'est lui qui l'avait fait remarquer en
début de sur tweets chat c'est vrai
qu'il faisait une tête mais bon après on
peut s'ils ont focalisé sur l'huile on
l'a vu à voir le coup de téléphone et
tout et on a vu avec ses expressions au
niveau du visage qui se détendent est
quoi c'était
assez amusant de
voir ça assez normal c'est des
compétiteurs ils veulent être un ils
sont trois normal c'est de l'orgueil du
jeune surtout que quand on t'annonce
pendant un mois et demi que tu vas être
numéro 1 quoi
ça fait des aveux quoi mais ok s'ils
sont contents peur qu'on prend
voilà longtemps
la draft donc là on en est aux pires 37
or le live le pic 38 ça encore san
antonio je crois
qu'elle gêne l'air mais il est transféré
à memphis quels sont leurs droits
ils sont chiants memphis
et procédés et trade à détroit où
son chien et son chat memphis année
après année alex
franchement là
kennedy chandler au deuxième tour pardon
mais ses joueurs il ya aucun monde où ça
réussit pas laisser partir teillouse
jones ou le bulgare d'un an
kennedy va faire il va faire un peu de
fric et puis après ce sera un meneur
backup qui coûtent pas charente voiture
dit que samassa marchait pas souvent
mais moi qui en heure sa marque et
semble en fait ça marche presque
conseillers des mecs qui ont fait quatre
ans tu vois je trouve
ça marche ça doit marcher c'est d'entrer
dans trois ans et les séries de playoffs
qu'ils changent leurs fins ils tiennent
cois pas avec jack la raviole je suis
pas choqué tu vois en bon sortir un
bénéfice
mathieu joinville non kamagaté planera
encore alors la seule france est pour
l'instant on attend on espère en 11 ou
qu'ici il n'y a plus que 20 choix parce
qu'en plus y en a deux de moins cette
année exactement
alors pierre on en est où il mène
normalement ça va plus vite non bat
normalement ce qu'on va plus vite mais
là ils sont sondés ilike de kyle
chandler
donc
bon alors mon est là et après le pic
d'après
si je dis pas de bêtises c'est cleveland
cleveland ils ont pris au challenge
league au lac noir
huawei a way se serait il a glissé riggi
rapport objections con
kamagaté aussi un
site charge du ready est tout gamin gâté
ça a du sens un petit peu
mais liddell aussi effectivement
ouais ils ont pris au cha ils veulent
ils veulent se caler sur les timeline
garlande moblie ce que je disais
début du live tout à l'heure la sueur
twitch l'idole des jeunes bien vu ça
évidemment c'est pas une blague discount
ça
donc après on a les cases en 39 et en 40
on a
les mousses
donc les mousses qui auront récupéré one
des lourds on rappelle à huy
et est quelqu'un d'autre non john kerr
stanley works et servait
le géant baobab non mais outré par ce
choix
ici agrégé et drafté par cleveland en 14
et gâteaux russe j'aime quand tu es dans
la position de doutre et à l'export du
loc'h
non il je comprends pas il ya plein de
joueurs dispos tu vas prendre l'autre la
4e de paramètres en page toujours je
suis au bout dm bien minnesota 1000 font
rien pour pour céder quoi
heureusement qu'ils ont amputé non
heureusement ils ont bien choisir parce
que la mélo il aurait posté là bas sans
pression
c'est fou
après j'espère que ça va bien se passer
tu vois
un week end a le bras on est toujours là
voilà là les chouchous de hughes
devait reconduire son contrat pour
l'année prochaine
passer pour un génie imagine si les deux
ont des vrais combats ouais mais tu sais
comme moi que le problème c'est quand
est choisi au deuxième tour on ne donne
pas forcément les clés quoi et
comment il est habillé marque tatum
pierre ste claire de façon très sobre
mais son tube ah ouais mais ils vont
revenir il y aura eu trois choix de
passer à o2i fulvio l'eau il ya des pubs
chipote les pendants pas exactement on
est en plein dedans
dix passagers fin ah ouais vous êtes
vous êtes à la force si les gars
y'a plus personne il vous enfermer dans
au pape ce qui augmente le 3 3 ils sont
allés se coucher non ouais ils ont été
conduits c'est gentil frais mais d'aller
qui voulaient s'incline
vous laisser du café chaud en partant et
puis voilà
non mais les gallois si les piques et on
voudrait ouais ouais on peut peut-être
comme on peut continuer à commande pour
moi on peut commenter 'j'ai de nardi
quand même on peut expliquer qui sait on
peut essayer de dire pourquoi il a
glissé manuel
l'image d'un
backing l'été annonce est très très haut
en sortie glisser une recrue 5 étoiles
qui a pris là le choix de j league et
c'est une saison à siwa c'est compliqué
mes gars et moi je les trouvais super
intéressant j'ai versé ou d'un board
dont je veux la voir dans le top 20
bornes
je ne sais plus exactement il est placé
cette amie l'avait 8e
mais jugez-moi j'ai énormément aimé ce
que j'ai vu un gars capable de secret
pour lui
d'être shootée moi je crois beaucoup aux
shoots mais il n'a pas très bien shooté
cette année en mai fais ce que j'ai fait
dans le rapport je mets ça sur le compte
qu'il est passé du ligne à 3 points
lycéenne à une ligne à trois points il
ya quasiment à mettre des différences
quoi il n'a pas eu la transition est
telle que la ligue européenne fiba bel
39 à 40 le 39 c'est qu'elle gagnait 39
c'est à dire adieu à l'écart mais il va
être h oralement
gauche julien il a fait tomber
l'étendage sava julien
du café en l'achetant café il
appartenait aux cetc têtes raides à
charlotte
merci pour les tweets monju je te
remercie
je peux reprendre si tu veux
je suis opérationnel
si mon ordinateur n'explose
au chapitre juste comme ça 41 sél et
pèse 42 les knicks 43 les clippers ok tu
as dit qu'ils khalifa dire pki
et bresse mac os
charles sobhraj
centers
pas eux qui font déjà pajot de doute
night away
je comprends pas trop idée est ce qu'ils
vont en foot ils vont avoir une super
équipe de
voir tous les athlètes externe ils les
ont tous c'est qui c'est qui leur leur
équipe affiliée à charlotte les
greensboro swarm hour en plus c'est
stylé
goitschel est greenboro swarm l'année
prochaine en kaikai jones james
goodnight bryce moon the world
j'ai eu tout d'abord bus
allait causer
du tort les pélicans 41 et johnny depp
bien sûr c'est bien joué
daniel jolidon en role players à côté
des gars voilà voilà
bravo ça marche avec les traits murphy
et tout cela bien sûr
tête j'aurais pris un backup five pour
le coup
on pourquoi pas mais tu vois derrière
valanciunas
et jax analyse ah oui mais ils le font
jouer 15 dont le oui
ah oui donc en fait inutile idol backup
de zion
après par an ça fait beaucoup non sur le
poste 3 4
murphy le journal
à l'autre après le tri va se faire tout
seul
avec son naturel
blessures
non mais c'est vrai blessures les trois
points qui rentrent
et donc khalifa diop un mot un mot un
geste sûr
être 7h et je pense grande canaria
sénégalais
honneur et la cavalerie destiné à
valence il a joué en euroligue je pense
qu'il va être taché
intro comme le définit bien nico
souci c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
l'offensive et pas l'hyper développer
mais ça peut être un backup sac dans
quelques années a
aucune c'est ça ça fonctionne
c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal et ça coûte pas cher
et et idji l' idole
bien
bien bien bien
ergen ses titulaires en trois
tailles on va être en quatre balles
jaunes ans risque pendant une grave
erreur jones il est titulaire aussi un
blog c'était en 4 passes qui a pas
ailleurs
une grange avait j'étais persuadé que
c'était jackson s qui était titulaire ce
poisson fois par mois
et qui joue avec mc collum herbe ah non
il y avait des ventes et g bon bref ils
ont un effectif pléthorique un ces pays
quand ils vous arrivent en récupérer qui
râlaient où il était croisés je pense
que ça va je sais pas ce qu'ils vont en
faire mais oui
donc pour
pour les donc dyson daniels
connecteurs comme ça tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure sur force team
manu a dit gros défenseur je suis
d'accord connecteurs offensif je suis
d'accord y'a pas besoin du ballon mais
si on lui donne il n'a pas le perdre
ouais
faut qu'il shoote à akwa 36% et c'est
bon
ouais c'est ça mais en fait faut pas
qu'ils le spacing donc en gros faut
qu'ils soient une menace correct
sur un peu ce qu'alonso bulls
ouais c'est ça ouais c'est ça meilleur
scénario et après jill idle
pareil
en tronquoy enfin un vrai joueur non
c'est vrai et pèse lourd mais
avec un bon comme on dit en bon jeu de
jambes
lâcher de balle très haut sur le tir la
pad il n'a pas de mal à shooter avec un
gars devant lui quoi
et puis à droite 41 à 3 points cette
année
aussi imaginer une
de semoule tant que ball avec lidl et
williamson en 5 aussi certains ça donne
des sensations
ça arrive c'est qu'il savait pas non
plus
on a le pic de new york a retenu qui
vient de tomber et c'est très fort
qu'ils qui va au dos du twin qui a
oublié blues incroyable le là le style
de
ça pour le coup le on se dit qu'avec
causse thibodeau ça fitte sur le papier
en tout cas
donc et pas encore annoncé mais ça va
être incessamment touche
non je ne crois pas
16 42 c'est le cas longueuil et le 41
sél et pèse
sur le lit et spillane brésil m meyer op
sans fils maël kamagaté quand même bah
oui
[Musique]
et manu
aux locaux un tour d'autant bon scott
je pense que c'est parfait pour lui il
vous me développer à merveille
je pense qu'il jouera je pense même
qu'il aura dix minutes dès l'année
prochaine
brimeux ron sa pose et des pics ça va
défendre le cercle je sais pas qui ils
ont là en titulaire ils vont dijon qui
fait se boucher tient bien
pour moi sur le papier c'est meilleur
mais enfin koloko six meilleures gt je
parle comme ça je n'ai pas trop regardé
ennemi installé mais qui se bouche et
moi je trouve bon bref on 21
mars bank 5e ekoloko sa valeur à ils
vont envoyer avec la rade le raptor 905
lie pour le développer ainsi
il il est long il est grand il est tout
ce qu ils aillent oui ça
aux clippers qui jouera demain il place
oui parce que l'équipe est au rang des
cinq meilleurs breakers pivot à zahia
touch times quel joueur incroyable c'est
bien des ouais mais vous match il va pas
rester toute sa vie peut-être
moment il ya des clippers et il ya
peut-être un truc un tueur en tout cas
il va avoir du temps à faire de la jenny
que je pense et d'intérieur lavoie s'est
pas non plus mes gars qui est bien c'est
qu'il défend
stefan juste qu'ils apprennent à
conduire bon et puis il va avoir dix
minutes l'ex ans
après aussi le contexte pour lui à
moussa de michigan et des pas top top
non plus terrible à côté d'un gros
troncs d'arbres la
ldj pas de casque daffé sur les celtic
j'ai écouté ta défi ça comment
tania ses couilles à nantes a pas dit ça
waouh
croyab lequel je crois c'est l'europe ça
oui mais non enregistrés chez j'ai très
hâte de voir moussa en nba
street et à défendre ce que c'est quand
même assez leurs sites high road où le
terrain qu'à un excellent que j'étais
france ihf s'il est dans le projet qui
se développent et j'ai hâte de voir ce
qu'il en fait
carrément
triste parce que j'aurais bien aimé le
voir cet x bow
low néophytes 43 wallace 15 pic
15 pic
qui n'est pas tombée encore
niveau pivot la saillie sont tous tombés
quasi mon début de deuxième tour apa
issement
ay ay ay ay ay racisme c'est le
dernier de la liste
après j'essaie de voir sur les autres
postes
[Musique]
ou
atlanta qui quitteraient de pouvoir
récupérer le 44 ou là ouais tu vois les
warriors
chercher externe
dynamique du renouveau jordan cool
yiu chung lee
sur des règles de tulane gras dire
ils sont capables de de draft et
derrière une si bonne qu'ils descendent
away
alors vas-y dindin uscis qui fait sur un
terrain ryan robbins
prix de l'an dernier deux conférences
moyenne pas de haut du panier en initier
à mettre cap au nord il fait il ya une
énorme envergure c'est important de qui
est très fort sur le ministe ans jusqu'à
trois ans doit se développer c'est un
défenseur qui défend de 1 à 3 ans initié
et quoi il va faire 2 10 d'envergure
pour 1 80 disent très très très très
long et voilà c'est toujours jeune il
n'a que 20 ans donc 19 points de moyenne
6 passes 3 passes et demi année à toledo
donc
moi j'aime beaucoup et je pense que
c'est ils vont se développer il manque
la chercher ils doivent avoir une idée
en tête
extrêmement fluide aussi ouais super
fine ballon après ils ont aussi fait des
dingueries au second tour pour rien il
saura p1 et son raté un
save a été chercher du jacob evans et
tous étaient pas ou feint
allen smile aguiche mais surtout aller
qu'ils ont toujours nokia qui c'est un
juif
il est où il finit filahi l'avoir repéré
libérer les ramener à libérer liu xin
mais oui justin y ont leur propre
kiosque mayotte à minnesota
est-ce que c'est pas un genre de
vanderbilt sans la balle poseurs d'écran
finisseur si elle sait qu'il faut le
développer quoi nous physiquement et
dans le jeu est-ce qu'ils ont tant pour
sa
prémisse de tir mais c'est
la défense et car il ya en fait qu'il ya
des prémices un peu partout il a le
physique c'est un jour où tu achètes les
flashs quoi
bayonne le physique compte 45 points à
perdre si sûr mais voilà c'est ça c'est
un picard entravent aussi lés
pic à venir
[Musique]
parce que ça du coup c'est le
pin kung ce que le long d'une autoroute
from soulas et pique c'est pour me au t1
j'ai dit ouais 48
donc c'est en 48 on a loupé dans 45
arrêts
parce que deux bases c'est
c'était charlotte ouais mais je crois
que tu les paies de du second tour ont
changé de mains c'est que tous
annoncent et ça c'est bien le p45 ok
donc là du coup avoir portland
de ba s'était même fils mais je sais pas
assez peut-être san antonio face quand
même si c'est mon t shirt frédéric sessa
donc à voir on va voir ces deux
là sur le live is annonce le pic
ouais donc il ya une hausse de just my
note donc c'était le pi des hornets
apparemment qui va aller au quine le
rouge
au niveau des joueurs donc ça fait deux
jours de memphis
combien d'arizona
3 du coup elle courra ou cardio 5 de
juke ou cinq majeur
ouais ouais ouais avec où on est mort
sert aujourd'hui
à y ait eu un trade je crois c'est quoi
les meilleurs joueurs disponibles
avec à l'ombre des williams kamagaté
besson
kendall bron dans le rhône vous êtes si
brawn gêne oculaire butler
ça c'est par
jean montéro
queen à orly
joignez du zinc vient d'arriver car si
j'apparais walker john lewis qui donne à
l'histoire elise pardon
non en fait on à la compensation pour le
pic
bois et de warriors numéro 4 ouais donc
ils ont envoyé le pic 51 et du lemon way
2000 - deviez c'est comme donner dix
balles michael d'euros une personne
molinar ouais ouais des to et ça
sans doute vrai
sans doute les bb brunes aussi au reggae
bois fera tomber
on est au combien alors
qu'ils ont celui qui l'avait
ryan robbins 44 c'est ça exactement 20
et 45 c'est josh manette
donc là sont tu veux
dominique barlow 6 mai stephen elop yade
mais que michael foster coq catalyser
drafté
non je dis non je disais en best buy les
bols à yako
michael foster
yatom barlow
petit flop de l'overtime et ils t'ont
pas du
rôle ils mettront leur leurs chips
prochain
ça va se transformer en chie plein à
craquer michael de l'emploi l'an
prochain ils ont
au moins deux loteries plus je pense
deux autres drafté sur ce que j'ai vu
c'est derrière on avait un débat est-ce
que les jumeaux thompson doivent partir
pourquoi il partirait
va être exposée face aux ménages pour
faire qu'observe si ce
qu il partirait encore une fois il faut
six portes lors de pics
cheminote silva ou alors à temps par les
milieux sont à l'erreur
ouais kamagaté aux nuggets
c'est pas mal et on en est à 3
3 tiba job center c'est pas mal an 46
ces mêmes binoche ou paix denver fort
libyen il est dans la vie vers
1,8 kit parfait mais tu vas être en
concurrence avec quoi part du temps de
l'an prochain indique nagy ya plus de
dix ans michael green
est ok bon ben voilà ça se débarrassant
coup de pied est depuis hier à pau à la
baisse en service
à ce stage
justement c'est peut-être pour apprendre
aussi à denver qui montrent le chercher
en plus donc
étonnant vire il peut même jouer
ensemble je pense prendre avec ils sont
six cartes pas mal peu
fier du pick and roll à deux
pianos
oui les griffes de ce qu'ils continuent
leur opération nba draft twitter wilaya
sion en 47 ha ouais
moi j'aime bien ça commence à faire
beaucoup de monde sur les mêmes postes
l'année à wigan se battre nous avons en
voit plein de trucs sur le mur là
derrière toi et tu vois si colas
le cal le la méthode calipari comme
ça mais
en même temps memphis calipari
l'affiliation à claire
corinne soûlasse produits sap avis si
young boys island l'an dernier un espèce
de quatre dont un peu petit mais très
long playmaker défensif moi j'aime bien
bonjour
claire des images de
is more et martha tout à coup
sinon quand même tu imagines
j'ai surtout s'il est là bas
c'est l'on tape tout le premier tour et
espère être choisi en fin de premier
tour n'est pas choisie et la têt les
équipes qui défilent qui défilent qui
défilent tu vois des mecs sur ton post
est pris ouais tu vois moussa est pris
tu vois khalifa diop qui est à peu près
au profil hier à toi est prêt les
équipes de avoir au moins cinq pic
d'avant
sans doute qu'il le savait un peu avant
kendall droit mais si brawn ne sont pas
encore draft et jeanne d'albret c'est
quand même assez fou break et narbonne
soit mille ans
nous la font l'avion high school il à
paul il n'a pas progressé non
il a toujours les mêmes lacunes donc
c'est
pas il était pas incroyable non plus en
reste cool été bon non mais le meilleur
lorsqu'il vint l'heure
est grave indique t'elle minnesota
échange de 48 à indiana
deuxième
vignal avoir à écrire chypriote
j'ai vu qu'il reste john butler
hugo buisson se serait pas très bien de
williams et de prendre une à prendre
très bonne williams
carlo matkovic eric
aubin voilà kendall il prône qu'il y
monte pour prendre quatre dames bronn
les pays sans ce
maintien pour le coup c'est pas si mal
joué ouais non c'est plutôt vraiment
intelligent
parce que il va avoir un peu de temps de
jeu tu vois en 4
l'a34 ça dépend ce qu'ils font c'est
avec auch et brice est et où il va
signer mais ouais ça dépend si carlyle a
un peu envie de
moi mais moi je le ferai jouer en 4
qu'elle n'a le brand à casela jackson à
côté
après il va falloir shooter un moment
donné mais ouais ouais
donc kendall branle ce turner est lié
ouais c'est vrai ailier ou beurs
athlétique vraiment très très athlétique
long tête au cercle même menton au
cercle
on leur donne quoi
ouais une sorte de aaron gordon moins
costauds peut-être moins puissant mais
avec plus de haendel
est à peu près le même shoot à l'arrivée
en nba je pense
gordon
basse et plus directs flotte un peu plus
mais
gordon s'est vraiment tu sens que ça
c'est une sorte de un boeing qui décolle
quoi c'est un buffle le volant
et du bohrie quoi
donc ismaël kamagaté à denver qui assure
le poste
physique nagy de mémoire il avait petter
cornelie mais ils n'ont plus
jamais que la green mill non plus direct
malgré une mais l'entraidé
il n'est pas vraiment devrait pas comme
ça qu'il avait des marques us cousine
l'année dernière andré way back up 5 mai
mais il ya un peu de place il ya enfin
je veux dire
c'est pas non plus des cônes en quoi
de l'imaginer avoir des minutes dès
l'année prochaine
pas des grosses grosses minutes mes
frangins oblet
vrai ouais
assez rigolo sa
part après ce que c'est un pic qui leur
appartient
ouais encore les fratries
ah bon ça peut se transformer les fans
de boston qui sont en train de frétiller
pierre je te vois aussi
à l'epic 53
avec ton chouchou qui est encore là
ouais
oui c'est encore là
après j'avoue que si nos vieux un choral
qui aurait pu descendre voir les
monstres
n'empêche que
on fera ça dans le bilan mais les
les gardes petit avec peu d'assurance en
défense et pas une création
extraordinaire eh ben ça dégage loin
je n'ai toujours pas jean montéro est
toujours pas sorti et mehdi ouatine est
morte pierre pour les celtics
mini board
dur est ce qu'elle vous badgés dessus tu
es dans la green room là
non parce que je me dis que je peux la
voir après ouais je voulais avoir rien
le progrès en ski bronn tu te crois
non moi j'aime pas je
suis un peu l'inversé grosso modo avec
hugo nappes les opposer dimanche john
baker web et leur
passion profit les trois intrigues ans
john boehner
il a un physique de chanteur c
est là qu il ya une couple de chanteurs
des années 70 il est incroyable je
l'imaginé avec une veste un peu trop
large là en train de souligner
non en vrai j'aime bien en vrai j'aime
bien en 53 sommes
ouais ça fait penser ou qui s'il avait
pris tour à tour les dernières comme ça
à la bobine tonnes d'ananas
mais benton c'était un peu un
jake larabia du pauvre y avait pour
certains chiffres avancés il y avait
aussi un petit truc mais c'est vrai je
te jure
on l'avait repéré sur bart or vic moins
évident et
de
minnesota qui prend matteo et
on la verra bien je l'avais mis là bas
dans mammadera dans mam au quai des
alpes est-ce que je suis pas quel
meilleur que sam décennies
nous
c'est que nous y as you et lewis est
appelée du coup
nous avons trois français trois italiens
de relance à 3 à 10 ans waouh baquero il
trompe comme italien ouais
non mais il y à fond quoi il allie il a
mangé
arrête
non je n'ai jamais vécu là bas ouais
c'est pas leonardo bonucci bien sûr mais
il a le drapeau italien dans son twitter
name le conseil
considère transalpin messieurs je sais
même pas s'ils parlent la langue
tu as terminé
3e avec comme ça
déjà il va pas en maître au
visage les vrais visages ceux des
braises levono grecs sont assumés
le big board existent sur le derrière
sharp est à vif émoi
dans le même groupe
il coupe c'est spaghetti pas italien
il ya des infos dans les infos dans les
commentaires les gober cela atlanta les
pèse et boston oh [ __ ] attends j'ai
raté des pics la cua vince williams
canal brand il a est modelée hockey
vince williams et hiva oa même this il
va mal que ce soit
trop canadien je pensais ça sharp
voiture un
used and in amenas et
aux les hawks qui prennent taris max
martin mais oui je l'avais mis dans mon
big board
mais oui yukon et du coup tu as le droit
d'en parler parce que moi je peux parler
ouais et demi attend et on va les
chercher sa fiche je ne crois pas mais
nous chercher ah ouais le guen a mis son
camp 7e ainsi que tu veux faire oui 23
ans parce que 3 4 10 et à rhodes island
à pélata yukon l'oeil à tout sauf le tir
mais sauf que cette impasse christophe
sauvetage est d'attirer à 43% à 3 points
mais je pense pas que son vrai niveau de
tir mais c'est un athlète très vrais
athlètes y fait un peu moins de deux
mètres ont ça peut être un small boat
small ball 4 si jamais ils shootent mais
vrai bon défenseur
expérimenté mais si un joueur pour
l'équipe de dick
n'ont rien donné on demande aussi dans
le chat sont peu parlé de spanoulis
vas-y
matteo qui prive les jeunes du real
madrid qui c'est qui a été prêté cette
année à crémone en première division
italienne où il a vraiment joué il a été
très bon c'est un porteur de balle très
très très très bon au revoir jouer très
fluide balle en main il s'est passé et
dribbler joue très bien et pick and roll
il est juste lent et pathétique
il est 10h with you est un stage chez
moustache
c'est mon avis et du stage qui hérite de
parents venir
c'est une station météo comme proxy là
je pense que ça
alors après sachant qu'il reste il reste
plus beaucoup de choix et nous les infos
enfin les infos que qu'on nous avait
donné que nico nous avait donné c'était
quand même qu'il y avait sa marée
et quand il s'appelle l'autre paf savent
cov
des promesses au second tour
j'arrive à faire
et on vous a pas entendu à l'année de
manu sur le pic de kids
maison qu'ils
ont pris moreno
qu'ils étaient là sur first team ils ont
donné leur avis mesurer
ce nom était déjà sur eux
a dit que c'était un joueur plug and
play il pouvait aider les attaques de
l'année prochaine qui était un peu plus
polyvalent qu'on pouvait le penser mais
la question c'est le plancher le plafond
il ya au plancher mais peut-être pas un
trait au plafond
mais ça est un bon joueur je pense
l'an prochain il a rempilé en 17,7 suis
pas choqué
et il sera en 17 7 pendant 12 ans
si l'imaginaire
j
c'est un derrière lui bien là qu'est ce
que tu penses de john williams 112 ha ok
ici
qui moi ouais bah j'aime bien
exceptionnel j'aime bien le truc c'est
que c'est ce qu'on disait c'est qu'avec
dieng williams à chaque fois qu'ils
faisaient une fois
c'est take tumulte écume sur des sons
des postes de froid mais c'est cuba pour
y faire quoi aju tu peux peut-être nous
parler d'asahi mobley quand même parce
que nous on a juste dit que c'était le
frère des vannes mais pour les fans 24
c'est quand vous irez vous saurez tout
content que diam's il aille à new york
en fait juste pour finir là-dessus
je pensais qu'ils allaient
à 0 et là bas c'est un grand bassam
anglais courant
de m suite il fait de mémoire de m suite
un petit peu comment dire n'est pas très
athlétique peu grassouillet quand même
[Musique]
et puis très bois quand même si après
paul mais polyvalent en attaque il a
fait beaucoup de choses cette année il a
fait des progrès en fait sur son passage
si c'était un peu il est arrivé un petit
peu quand une star avant
que son frère soit là 1 cette année je
trouve qu'il a joué plus
comme en dit plus dans l'équipe quoi il
a été beaucoup plus
carrés dans ce qu'il faisait il soutint
peut y passe un peu
c'est papa je trouve pas que ce soit un
très très bon défenseur mais il fait de
la
voir un polyvalent en attaque et en
défense plutôt
[Musique]
mon avis
white male droite
mais à 1,5 de matuidi fait ans
les bombes et un dribble correct quoi
pour sa taille un bon dribble il a des
bonnes mains
on donne de la série
on a le pic de new york tyrese martins
tew pardon
hein
c'était
alors de basse avaient été blessés
depuis ces attentats
martin en 52 on a le pic seimat
malkovich
qui a été pris par les pèse
carlo matkovic
il jouit lui aussi avec
caro matt collins qui joue aussi à eau
comment bébé mégabits match va quoi là
il faut qu'ils changent tout le temps ni
joyau megan aux arts d'enghien oise
alors voilà sa chance c'est sûr chaque
année même donc deux joueurs de la même
équipe après jovic drafté par les lots 8
et toi mon apport lèvres de battre
commises dans le podcast eu raison
intérieur avec codex profite d'un profil
tâche en deuxième partie de second tour
c'est un joueur que qui pour le coup
je sais pas s'il va être taché 1 ce
qu'il a il a l'air plus près que la
majorité des intérieurs ou des européens
même qu'ils sont qui sont draft et là
il ya un peu plus âgés aussi je vous dis
bien déjà international h et des creux
rails les croates
il est drafté c'est qui
quand
les pélicans
mais ouais mon avis je sais pas s'ils
vont le garder
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des questions dans
le lay
atelier il y a quelqu'un qui me disais
bon soir enfin maintenant c'est même
comme tout bon roumaine vu leur 6h15
pierre ouais j'ai vu la vie en pense
quoi c'est pas
gênant c'est pas lui
après
j'ai dit valls d'ellison la plus belle
crinière de toute l'année si si
c'est un freshman qui a déçu c'est un
projet faut croire
qu'il ya une il ya des qualités
athlétiques indéniables après il
travaille encore
donc bon après c'est un pic 53 tu peux
tu peux arrêter ses mains sur une façon
qu'on à jiegu l'an prochain ouais ouais
oman celtics
il se sera bien là d'ailleurs à
bien faire ça et puis voilà quoi
hugo
bon après dans la logique savoir en
début d'année qu'on attendait très haut
qui descend tu prends un but qui descend
vers c'est pas forcément me vois comme
biture boston l'an dernier quoi là où
les primes votre nouvelle
donc d'ailleurs il y en a même pris
exactement cinquante profs viennent en
outaouais
ça y est je suis à jour donc la question
est de savoir si maintenant hugo besson
red bull
et yoan alcouffe
et
yannick eijssen à 11,54
washington
ah ouais ouais j'ai et c'est sûr qu'il
été drafté s'ils restent assez qui était
qu'il avait une proposition avec un
stage
jeanne a bien fait son travail
donc yannick n osa on a parlé aussi dans
le live sur les
internationaux
d'aidé des bons outils un sénégalais
ac oui c'est diop et badji
hockey enzo za congolais l'ont mobile
mais bruno
47 ans
m'a dit qu'on arrêtait non mais là il ya
les ya des rumeurs mais hyper brut way
qui joue à malaga et joué au début je
jouais là particulier de particularité
d'avoir quitté les l'italie dans un
coffre de voiture
ah bon ah ouais il avait signé quoi 15
ans avec la stella doué et il a vu que
c'est un copain carlos ghosn c'est
exactement ce que j'aime bien
j'attendais de la place et
fia sur renault
c'est beau ça
qu'est-ce qu'il a souffert carlos ghosn
samedi que ça ça me foule ça me fout le
bordel
le pic 55 qui va finalement à milwaukee
qui était de base agnostiques ne sait
pas encore qui c'est
au 15 heures
il va à washington
c'est ça
[Musique]
j'entends toujours la sermone quoi
ouais on a décidé de plus parler alors
il y avait déjà eu il ya des gens qui
font le ménage parce que je brûle les
lèvres de la de bouger je
salue les bons serveurs où les gens
milwaukee bien d'acheter deux pics 55 et
58 si on faire comme l'année dernière ou
encore carnaval
par des pointages yannick comme ça ouais
c'est ça fait plaisir à la famille c'est
peut-être qu'ils vont prendre ziga
s'amarrer
si c'est ça c'est rigolo
donc ils achètent le combien 55 56 58 58
donc 55 warriors et 58 au psuv c'est ça
ouais
il faudra me cacher
du coup il reste qu'elle pique
les gars david roadie
premier tour
la conférence mais ttc tétouan cette
année julien
c'est à dole de mission sport loterie
monde attend mais il a dit abel mathurin
d'haleine terry david rosen janelle
williams c'est la folie 1 c'est la folie
de la côte ouest cette année là bas mais
même à zahia mobile il est drafté tu
vois franchement tu aurais pu présenter
des mecs un peu plus là ça se trouve
mohamed guèye il aurait dû rester je
voulais juste qu'il va
peut-être par les bucks se serait pas
une mauvaise
hygiène brasil quand même
aux meilleurs aube sans délai en ciblant
pour pour golden state y est ils ont
clairement lui mon mode draft en
décline
et oui oui oh boy tension et meyer est
disponible hugo besson tient à yugo
hugo hugo hugo bucks en arthies en
sortie de banc
oui parce que diane si brawn c'est un
peu redondant que janice c'est un peu le
janice de
la caroline
cette équipe déjà à t'en as tu es dont
et di vicenza c'était le michael jordan
de du rhode island entre de la roueyre
dans un état du delaware est
un état nul
de labouheyre
dans l'est
j'ai pas la capitale pas faire les jeux
on a quand même 180 personnes qui sont
en train de regarder on est sûr qu'ils
sont pas endormis en laissant leurs
écrans ouvert parce que j'aime
[Musique]
ken bray serions-nous la tête en sang
merci à vous en tout cas
on va faire un live débrief ça va être
rigolo
on va donc on va taper sur qui les
hornets
les kings
c'est toujours les mêmes aussi ouais
ouais
on va dire bravo pistols ouais ok même
si son corps sur les mêmes aussi ça dort
pas ça les a réveillés
même fils bah ouais même fils teints
ont fait des drafts chaque année pour
que ça se ressemble
les jours
bah oui
c'est toujours la même histoire
bon après peut-être que sacramento à
faire les playoffs on nous regarde à
hong kong c'est incroyable ah ouais mais
à hong kong la cua hisser le matin
tranquille aux
basses et le matin ici aussi il ya plus
cette
plus est par rapport à vous
au moins sept ans et plus ouais c'est ça
plus être surpris c'est à eau
les spurs est vrai que bon c'est pas
trop quoi master ils vont [ __ ]
potentiel quattro il vous faire des
tests mais en fait il est je pense que
et sur le plateau de la force hymne au
cluzeau de savoie ça va mon gars
c'est un très fort les délocalisations
folle qui sortent plus je vous
déconseille d'y aller mais les bienvenus
au mas
on s'active déjà il à faire je suis
désolé mais
guy santos
[Musique]
vous l'aurez vu qu'ici
il ya les klaxons des klaxons dans la
rue
tu rigole mais ici sont tellement fou de
lille vont ils vont être fous ils vont
être
10 ans taux servis janice
la mi-août on sait qu'on sait ce qu alex
par le grade à la summer league
ben non mais attends
gmt je suis hyper content j'ai tapé un
scout inri portes hier je pensais que
personne n'avait jamais de lire
la boxe nation pas dire donc guy santos
il est né à brasilia
donc il ya pas grand chose à faire il
faut à brasilia du nom du foot même pas
trop la politique
et il s'est mis au basket il jouait dans
le minas gerais bel état on mange bien
les deux dernières années l'année
dernière en fait il a une taille
pré-draft parce qu'il shoote hyper bien
pendant un an c'est un gars qui fait de
m il en donne vraiment bon pour 2 m
95 kg
et l'année dernière il shoote âge entre
30 50 % je sais plus mais c'est pas mal
et du coup la hype mais il se retire au
dernier moment et là il y retourner
cette année alors qu'il n'a pas bien
shooter cette année il a perdu plus de
ballons il n'ya pas très bien joué
et bah il est drafté bon bah c'est bien
moi je suis je suis content pour guy à
chaleix un pass qu'atlanta prix luc
traversons
là peut-être ce guide est que guy va
être taché en australie aussi peut-être
comme tu dis lousada comme didier
lousada mais bon c'est une grande
nouvelle pour le basket ball brésil
celle
qui a un avenir incroyable radieux avec
parlons-en
avec sami rodriguez carl edwards auberge
cafetiers et reno camille au dos santos
est très très bon aussi ainsi que le vix
victor capte au saut alors je peux vous
parler de deshors bien chier ou et
eduardo berche très dans le catch and
shoot à trois points
bon ça arrivera dans trois ans
c'est pas mal déjà commencé appareils de
l'ue traverse ouais tu y es parti
nuque longue
australien il avoir à
de mémoire bons joueurs
3-4 plus tôt de mémoire c'est un peintre
ce que j'ai le plus vieux des trois
meilleurs scouting report sur le site
mais il également il est également
peintre en bâtiment
quand vous aider
la coupe de cheveux d'un viking
non il apparemment il est quand même pas
très adroit de ses mains ce que nous
disait nico nico l'aiment bien il dit
voilà il se bat
c'est en vigueur
quand on dit d'un joueur qui se bat
c'est volt se bat quoi quand on dit
entraîné ce
que devient pas caboclo jedi très bonne
question qu'a boucle
après je crois qu'ils jouent au brésil
non oh qu'il est revenu
futur mvp bah je crois que j'ai vu les
yaraye hier c'était fou le brésil hier
j'ai regardé plein de matchs et il est
dans les meilleurs scores en tout cas il
ya un cabot claude à mr scruff
au louvre
[Musique]
bah oui diddy moi je suis d'accord avec
le chat
mais si on me dit dans le shop vous avez
un squeegee portes de guy santos plus
complète nba.com et a cru qu'on était
qui mais
tous nos scouting report sont plus
compliquées nba.com
il comprit guy santos qui accède au
statut de légende grâce au moment qui
vient de nous faire vivre quand même
je reçois des notifications il ya des
feux allumés à sao paulo c'est fou
je dois je vais essayer je vais essayer
d'acheter son maillot je vous promets je
le masne le maillot du du minasse 1 2 3
le nom du club pour samedi avec le bayou
récap avec le maillot de licences ou
saas est très beau il est dégueulasse le
maillot je crois en plus on pique 57
portland jabbari awake est assez bien
fait un petit post cac qui sont à peu
près 4 l on avait la clé c'est le tien
mes défenseurs incroyable et super épais
super le grand pour sa
part car
c'est un mec qui est beaucoup descendus
aussi non car donc vite évidemment
annoncée dans les vingt ans en début
d'année et qui se retrouvent yahoo
[Musique]
105 60 voix toujours quoi d'une blessure
non plus ça sent pas très bon je
m'arrête brave carrière guy santos
et des travailleurs semblent
mecs se sont vus la nba les leçons des
ducs traverse le qubo besson
et que
si ça y est 1,58 il est tombé un
débat alors
echarif paul mignot lakers incroyable
jamais quoi c'est vous qui voyez les
sioux chiffonniers
c'est fou
à l'ombre des williams non drafté en
annexe 1 ouais john butler si bronn gaby
brown à londres
et des toux et des ki moon est
molina guider d'ici
l'arrivée
d'eric boullier a oui il va jouer avec
miami c'est bon c'est fini il est il est
une grave si non il va ya
on va y aller les gars y'a des gens qui
font le ménage
wen votation nous aussi on va y aller
les six heures et demie on est là depuis
deux heures se fait 80 plaisir merci à
vous au sens
557 personnes vous êtes des dingues
n'entend pas aller sont revenus de télé
bougez la
non non
toujours pas
tu vois les gars
jus à bientôt
alex escompte entrant là
je sais pas tu entends pas avec ce nom
bon bah on va faire en langage des
signes je vais passer le message merci
beaucoup pour d'avoir été là
merci à al ain à manu on souhaite bien
sûr beaucoup rage à hughes qui a dû nous
quitter précipitamment on vous donnera
des nouvelles évidemment
un coucou à tous ceux que vous n'avez
pas vu mais qu'il faut un gros taf
derrière je pense à antoine maxime à
yacine à à nathan
antoine qui gère le site maintenant nico
on a vu romain qui était habile enfin
voilà toute la team et qui balancent
qu'on trouve très vite de toute façon et
qui on vous fait des bisous en attendant
n'oubliez pas envers year procès où vous
connaissez taillez vos potes qui sont
fans de franchie tout ça tout ça est
abonné vous bien sûr sur twitch sur
twitter sur instagram
et voilà et on se retrouve très vite by
your mind